damn
[Music]
well i gotta say i'm incredibly excited
to be part of dao i mean
the community built is absolutely [ __ ]
the community
your only responsibility is to get their
liquidity on the table
you got a girlfriend no
i'm engaged i'm
my fiance um son me she uh
she's a blockchain dev
congratulations
thank you
think about sunmi name of the game
move the money from your lp's pocket
into your pocket
lp
liquidity provider right but if you can
make your lp's money at the same time
it's advantageous for everyone correct
no
number one rule in crypto nobody i don't
care if you're suzu or sulong tang
nobody knows if the token will go up
down sideways or in [ __ ] circles
at least of all the stout fighters solar
fugazi
you know what a fugazi is
for gazi it's uh it's a fake it's
a fugazi it's a wise it's a woozy it's
very dust
it doesn't exist it's never landed it is
no matter it is not on the elemental
chart
it's not [ __ ] real all right all
right
stay with me we don't create [ __ ]
we don't build anything well we are
building a decentralized reserve
currency you know we are bringing
stability into what the [ __ ] even is
stability
from whose perspective
the us dollar
gold bitcoin
your girlfriend's birkin
stability utility credibility just more
words to mask the same old protocol of
give me your money and i promise i'll
make you more money
maybe oh my god give yourself a little
bit more credit it's a little bit more
complex than that right i mean most d52
protocols are nobody knows how it works
we just take their garbage coins and put
them in a stew with other useless coins
and call it a treasury
no it's a whole new thing
the code is all forked from olympus i
don't [ __ ] know how it works
like i said we don't build anything so
if you have users who staked and earned
10 000 api in the last few weeks
he's all [ __ ] happy he wants to swap
his tokens liquidate take his [ __ ]
money and run home
you don't let him do that no because
that would make it real
right what do you do
you get another brilliant idea a special
idea another situation another
staking reward
to reinvest his earnings
then he will
every single time because they're
[ __ ] addicted
and we just keep doing this again and
again and again
meanwhile he thinks he's getting [ __ ]
rich
which he is
on paper
but you and me we're taking home cold
hard cash by dumping our governance
tokens on them [ __ ]
right right
[Laughter]
that's incredible sir
i can't tell you how excited i am oh
they don't call me sifu for no reason am
i right
right
all right
come on
[Music]
oh
yes yes yes
oh [ __ ]
all right
cool
so again
yo i'm hosting a live event in may in
new york city we're going to rent out a
space so we can watch my next unreleased
video together then we can have a
fireside chat and then we can just hang
out we're going to have catering so
we're going to get dinner prosciutto and
[ __ ] this is all going to be free more
details and updates on my discord
channel however there are limited spots
because the space can only fit about 40
people so you're gonna have to apply for
a google form and tell me how cool you
are and then i'll select you that form
is on my discord channel so it's discord
dot gg slash fax doggos oh and if you're
a vax doggos you're automatically
accepted so yeah this is gonna be my
first live event i'm super excited
please come peace